on a bien commandé chinois grecque et a
dernièrement et des hot-dogs or j'étais
tellement dans le coltan qu'est-ce qu'on
a fini par regarder
il me semble que c'etait l'écho de la
peur ou amour danger non je m'en
souviendrai s'ils avaient eu tori
spelling tu sais il devrait faire un
film inspiré de la chute de tori
spelling dans son resto japonais
teppanyaki le grill de la mort dont vu
le peu de temps qu'on as qu on oublie la
visite de la ville très bien alors on
fait la version courte ya un débat
houleux sur le fait de garder ou non la
cabine téléphonique
il se changera ou superman quand il
viendra nous sauver de ben affleck
c'est exactement ce que je leur ai dit
patrice pas question de faire des rusty
pour moi un truc consiste en plus des
tacos oreilles tu ranges tout de suite
fait mine de ne s'est pas du tout le
moment
maman oui je sais c'est magnifique ça
fait lui s'est fait le mur entier c'est
le moment pour moi d'être sans attaches
et toi ça ne te dérange pas que tu as
failli vagabonde ainsi oui mais pour
l'instant elle jack kerouac is elle part
sur la route en prenant du pilote mais
après avoir pris du pays en tant
qu'hommes salle de bains thule adventure
d' aller vomir je suis globalement 17
personnes au juste 3
si je pouvais
je croyais savoir exactement ce que je
voulais où j'allais mais ces derniers
temps tout à coup tout sans le flou mais
on est très heureux tous les deux dit
moi je ne sais pas comment vous faites
étaient mariés pendant cinquante ans la
moitié de man a disparu d encombres ma
vie si ça t'apporte de la joie tu peux
le garder
sinon temps débarrasse aucune joie maman
il prend les choses de la salle à manger
elle ne m'apporte aucune voix
je me sentais complètement perdu ces
derniers temps j valfré boulot j'ai pas
d'argent côté-ci pas de sous-vêtements
quoi j'aurais pu devenir quelqu'un tu es
que tu donnes tout cela est extrêmement
excitant non là c'est bon maintenant la
partie a répété est terminée c'est pour
des moments comme ça que je vis
battu en mai
oui
c'était carrément pornographiques
tu as perdu ton d'entrée a fait du bien
lequel